i'm joined by steven task of at no
Stephen let's start by explaining at
know and how it fits into the European
scene in telecommunications well thank
you Brian well Edna is one of the
largest association of telecom operators
in Europe together I think we represent
about two-thirds of the investment
capacity in networks in Europe this
group of operators has been building
telecommunication networks for the last
decades in Europe and we're really
committed to continue to building
state-of-the-art networks both mobile
and fixed in Europe and that's also the
reason why we here today because this is
a conference about investment and
investment is really the core activity
of our members and I think you were very
pleased by what you heard in the opening
plenary about about regulation in Poland
in particular but it was a welcoming
message a thing absolutely i think that
the polish regulated has said some very
interesting things today at the
conference basically what was said is
that we need to review european
regulatory framework and we should
really start for less regulation that
what we have done in the previous years
I think we should all recognize that the
rules that we had in in in Europe were
made sense probably 10 to 15 years ago
but now if we're looking ahead of us
what we will need for the next 10 to 50
years or different rules at the rules we
had in the past and it's very
encouraging that that also regulators
are not saying is that it is important
that we really want to work with them
all on making sure that we have
state-of-the-art rules in Europe that
really stimulate people for investing in
in faster networks for innovating and
making sure that we have the best
digital backbone for our digital society
in Europe so a last question if i gave
you a blank sheet of paper what sort of
rules would you put down there well i
think much less than what we had in the
past i think we should really look at
what are the rules we still need today
what are the rules we don't need anymore
and what can you really leave to the
market
on its on its own so and the real the
rules that we leave in place should
really be rules that are stimulating
investments are stimulating innovation
that's going to be key we should really
only be it's really important to
understand that we are working in a
globalized world and so we must make
sure that the competitiveness of our
digital economy in Europe really is
comparable and even beat other regions
in the world so this is a global
competition in which are playing so we
really need to make sure that the rules
we have in place to post is that grill
in place stimulate the European digital
economy to grow and to prosper and to
bring welfare tool to all European
citizens so that's key for me that's
really interesting thank you very much
for talking to us thank you Brian visit
you so in a fast-changing world
regulation needs to change with it to
keep pace